جانب اساسي فعلا انه نظام مؤسسات الصحفيه
في المملكه لا يخدم التطور لا توجد
مسؤوليه على اعضاء ولا توجد الملاك ولا
توجد رغبه هم حاصدوا ارباح في الدرجه
الاولى اكثر منهم مستفيدين بالتالي لم
نشهد تطوير لم نشهد تدريب لم يسبق لمؤسسه
صحفيه كانت فقيره في التدريب بشكل كامل لم
تخصص ميزانيات للتدريب والتطوير كان هناك
عنايه بشكل وكان مردود مرتاح بالتالي لما
ضعفت الحاله متراجع الاعلام المتغير
المشهد السوء بسبب البعد والانفصال ولا
تكلمت عنه شغف ما الذي يجعل شركه تنجح شخص
ملاك معنيين بتحقيق الارباح ما الذي يجعل
المؤثره تنجح في المقابل هؤلاء في
المقابله النظام لا يعني وجود الشغاف لانه
قد لا يكون له الملاك
ممكن يكون عقارب لا علاقه له في القصه
فبالتالي هذا كان غياب كبير جدا وخطورته
ليس فقط في سقوط مؤسسات صحفيه او صحف
معينه انهيار لا خطوره انه في غياب المشهد
الصحفي نحن يعني نعاني من العقم الصحفي في
جفاف لا يتولد اجيال جديده لا كليه
الاعلام تقوم بدورها ولا صعب تقوم بدوره
ولا وزاره الاعلام تتحمل شريف فبالتالي
سيكون هناك كفاف ماذا سينشي عن هذا الجفاف
ينشف رغم دخول
وسائط الاجتماعيه
المرحليه لكن ستنتهي احنا ما تنتهي لن
يكون لدينا اعلام